Game of Thrones prequel series, House of the
Dragon, is coming in 2022.
It’s based on George RR Martin’s book
Fire And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s
yet unfinished Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
Fire & Blood covers the tales from the legendary
Aegon the Conqueror all the way up to the
civil war, the Dance of the Dragons, that
nearly tore their dynasty apart, while Fire
And Blood volume 2 will continue from where
part 1 ended, and will cover Blackyre rebellions
and go all the way to the Mad King and Robert's
Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
House of the Dragon is based on the Targaryen
history and therefore it's not surprising
that this show will feature many Targaryen
dragons, and the most powerful of them all
- Balerion the Black Dread.
Balerion, called the Black Dread, was a dragon
of House Targaryen.
He was ridden by King Aegon I Targaryen during
his Conquest, alongside his sister Queen Visenya's
Vhagar,
and his sister Queen Rhaenys's Meraxes.
Other known riders of Balerion were King Maegor
I Targaryen, Princess Aerea Targaryen and
King Viserys I Targaryen.
Balerion died of old age in 94 AC during the
reign of King Jaehaerys I Targaryen, being
around two hundred years old.
Balerion's scales and wings were black.
His fire was black, sometimes with swirls
of red.
When he was in the fullness of his power,
his flames could melt steel and stone, and
fuse sand into glass.
Balerion was named after the ancient god of
the Valyrian Freehold.
He was born in Valyria, and was one of the
five dragons Aenar Targaryen brought with
him when he fled to Dragonstone to survive
the Doom of Valyria.
After the other four of Aenar's dragons died,
Balerion became the last creature to have
seen the Valyrian Freehold in its prime.
Balerion was the largest of all the Targaryen
dragons since Aegon's Conquest.
His wingspan was so large that his shadow
could engulf entire towns when he passed overhead.
His teeth were as long as swords, and his
jaws were large enough to swallow an aurochs
whole, or even one of the hairy mammoths that
are said to roam the cold wastes beyond the
Port of Ibben.
By 93 AC, Balerion had finally stopped growing.
He had grown sluggish and heavy and was difficult
to rouse.
When Prince Viserys Targaryen claimed the
dragon that year, the dragon struggled to
take to the air.
But back to prime Balerion.
Balerion was claimed by Lord Aegon Targaryen,
sometime before he married his sisters Visenya
and Rhaenys.
Aegon became involved in the wars in the Disputed
Lands when Pentos and Tyrosh approached him,
inviting him to join a grand alliance against
Volantis, and he chose to heed their call.
Mounting Balerion, he flew east to meet the
Prince of Pentos and the magisters of the
Free City,
then flew to Lys in time to set ablaze a Volantene
fleet trying to take the city.
Afterwards, Aegon turned his attention to
conquering the Seven Kingdoms, during which
he flew on Balerion.
Aegon then began planning the invasion of
Westeros long before launching the attack,
spending time incognito on Balerion in air,
scouting Westeros, visiting Westerosi cities
and castles and gaining intelligence on the
different houses, their lords and their vassals.
Aegon, his two sister-wives and their three
dragons led a scant few thousand troops in
invading the entire continent of Westeros.
Aegon descended on Lords Mooton and Darklyn,
killing both of them during Aegon's first
test.
Next, Aegon took Balerion to Harrenhal, where
King Harren Hoare took refuge in his formidable
fortress.
When Hoare had not yielded by sunset, he took
Balerion high up and descended inside the
castle walls, and put the castle to flame.
Balerion's dragonfire burned so hot that the
towers of Harrenhal went up like candles,
melting and twisting into the shapes they
retain to this day.
King Harren and his sons all perished, ending
the line of House Hoare.
Despite being vastly outnumbered, Aegon was
able to secure victory after victory using
Balerion.
Aegon next rode Balerion in the Field of Fire,
beside his sisters on Vhagar and Meraxes.
Vhagar was a she-dragon of House Targaryen
and like Balerion, she was also named for
one of the gods of Old Valyria.
Vhagar was large enough that one could ride
a horse down her gullet,
but not as large as Balerion nor as strong.
It's also said that Vhagar's breath was so
hot that it could melt a knight's armor and
cook him inside, but not as hot as Balerion's
which could melt steel and stone.
Meraxes, like Vhagar was also a she-dragon
of House Targaryen and like two of her siblings,
she was also named for one of the gods of
Old Valyria.
Meraxes was larger than Vhagar, but smaller
than Balerion.
Meraxes could swallow horses whole.
Between the three dragons, four thousand men
were burned to death, including King Mern
IX Gardener, resulting in Targaryen victory.
Aegon's army was defeated, but the Targaryen
dragons (Balerion, Meraxes, and Vhagar) allowed
Aegon to achieve a great victory at the Field
of Fire, which resulted in the death of Mern
IX Gardener,
and the surrender of Loren I Lannister.
When Aegon learned that King Torrhen Stark
had crossed the Neck and was leading army
into the riverlands, he raced ahead of his
army on Balerion to meet the threat.
When the Targaryen host was encamped at one
side of the Trident and the northern host
on the other side, Torrhen's brother Brandon
Snow offered to assassinate the sleeping dragons.
Recalling the destruction the three dragons
had caused on the Field of Fire,
Torrhen instead submitted to Aegon.
According to song, at the end of the war Balerion
helped to forge the Iron Throne by melting
the swords of Aegon's fallen enemies.
Aegon treated the defeated lords with respect
and allowed each region to retain its own
laws and customs.
Aegon often travelled with Balerion through
the realm with maesters who educated him on
each region's local customs and history.
Aegon later flew Balerion into battle during
the First Dornish War, where he suffered the
greatest loss when his sister, Queen Rhaenys
Targaryen and her dragon Meraxes fell from
the sky after a shot from a scorpion took
the dragon in the eye.
The war took a different turn after this.
Aegon's fury and grief at the loss of his
wife was such that he headed for Dorne himself.
Accompanied by Visenya, the last two Targaryens
rained fire upon the desert strongholds to
break the Dornish.
The next two years were known as the Dragon's
Wroth, a period when every Dornish castle
felt the fury of the dragonriders.
The only castle spared was Sunspear, the seat
of House Martell, in hopes that the Dornish
would turn against their liege lords.
The strategy failed and Dorne remained unconquered.
After Aegon's death, Balerion was claimed
by his son Prince Maegor, who had long coveted
his father's mount, and had not claimed another
dragon because he considered all others unworthy.
After Jonos Arryn imprisoned his brother Lord
Ronnel and declared himself independent of
the Iron Throne, Maegor rode the Black Dread
to the Vale and put down his rebellion.
When Maegor was exiled to Pentos as a punishment
for his polygamous marriage, he took Balerion
with him.
After his brother King Aenys I died, Maegor
flew back to Westeros on Balerion to claim
the Iron Throne.
In his reign as king, Maegor used Balerion
in the burning of the Sept of Remembrance
and in many other battles against the Faith
Militant.
In the Battle Beneath the Gods Eye,
Maegor used Balerion to kill his nephew Prince
Aegon and his dragon Quicksilver.
After Maegor's death, Balerion returned to
Dragonstone, where he made his lair.
Balerion was claimed as a mount by princess
Aerea Targaryen in late 54 AC.
They disappeared and went missing for more
than a year.
King Jaehaerys I Targaryen sent expeditions
to try and locate Balerion and the young princess,
and the master of coin, Rego Draz,
offered a reward for any information on their
whereabouts, but none came forward that were
credible.
Balerion was the largest living dragon in
the world, but there were no sightings of
the dragon anywhere.
Septon Barth believed that the lack of sightings
suggested that Balerion was no longer in Westeros.
Balerion returned to King's Landing in 56
AC, descending into the courtyard of the Red
Keep with Aerea barely clinging to him.
The princess was severely ill, and died soon
after.
Barth's accounts describe wounds and half-healed
scars on Balerion.
The dragon bore a huge jagged rent down his
left side, almost nine feet long, and fresh
blood still dripped from the wound, hot and
smoking.
Barth speculated that, when Aerea claimed
Balerion,
she was unable to bend the dragon to her will,
and instead the dragon had taken her to the
place he had been born, Valyria.
What could cause such wounds to mighty Balerion
remains unknown.
Shortly thereafter, Balerion became the first
dragon to be housed in the Dragonpit,
where he was guarded by the Dragonkeepers.
Balerion remained at the Dragonpit.
When Princess Alyssa Targaryen came to the
Dragonpit to claim a dragon of her own in
75 AC,
the Dragonkeepers persuaded her not to try
and claim Balerion, insisting that the dragon
had become old and slow, suggesting to her
that she would much more prefer a faster dragon.
The last rider of Balerion was Prince Viserys
Targaryen, who entered the Dragonpit to claim
the dragon in 93 AC.
Balerion was hard to rouse, and struggled
when Viserys urged him into the sky.
They flew around King's Landing three times,
although Viserys later confided to his father
that he had originally intended to fly Balerion
to Dragonstone.
However, fearing the dragon lacked the strength
to do so, Viserys had opted otherwise.
Balerion died in 94 AC, less than a year after
Viserys claimed him as his mount.
Along with eighteen other Targaryen dragon
skulls,
Balerion's skull hung on a wall in the Red
Keep's throne room.
After Robert's Rebellion, King Robert I Baratheon
had the skulls removed from the throne room,
and stored them in a dark cellar.
That is the story of the mightiest Targaryen
dragon.
He's seen it all and been through it all,
from the Valyrian Freehold in its prime
to conquering the Seven Kingdoms and living
to see generations of Targaryen's rule in
Westeros.
Balerion was the largest dragon ever seen
in Westeros.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs upand I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!